era un dispositivo de logística que
nunca hemos visto en este país desde las
próximas horas hasta cuando concluya el
funeral de estado de isabel segunda la
reina que estuvo en el trono 70 años y 7
meses se ha dicho que la policía está
trayendo efectivos adicionales unos
10.000 desde otras regiones del reino
unido- para poder prestar toda la
seguridad que se necesita para estos
días como lo mencionas entonces una vez
la reina sea trasladada al parlamento
para abrir las 24 horas y por 4 días la
cámara ardiente la familia real y el
arzobispo de canterbury le realizarán
una pequeña ceremonia religiosa y luego
se abrirán las puertas al público les
cuento que desde ya las personas están
haciendo fila pese a que se ha pedido
que no acampen para la apertura de esa
palacio de westminster que será
aproximadamente 4 aproximadamente en 24
horas se les ha advertido a las personas
que tendrán que esperar entre 35 y 40
horas y que no podrán ni tomar fotos y
llevar flores